now let's have a look at this for a
second just like we've seen before
integration by part is not always
obvious for how to use it this is a
product right this is a product so we
just have to think about well what's a
nice convenient way that we can slice
this up and get something useful out of
it so I can get a youth and a DB ok so
I'm going to go okay now how would you
like me to divide this up just have a
think about it for a second okay what I
want just like I had in this form is I
want something that's going to get
progressively smaller and smaller and
smaller and something else which more or
less stays the same which was the edx
term over here so when I have a look at
this how can i divide this up okay any
suggestions here okay so i could
multiply by one do remember were
integrating sine inverse okay um I chose
sine inverse and one and then it sort of
worked out it's kind of nice because I
think you ended up getting something
like I think your VD you ended up being
from memory I think it was something
like this that is that right something
uh yeah because that was that was your
integral there that was the v GG it was
fired because this you can deal with how
this is reverse chain rule right if you
let u equal one minus x squared and
you've got you to the negative a half
and then you got Deion DX up there so
that's cool well a version of it use x
minus 2 okay so that's fine in this case
though if I choose cars n to the x + 1
and put them in somewhere here well
which one is going to be which which
will be you and which will be given you
would be yeah you'd put cause enter the
X here right because you don't integrate
that guy right that's just gonna stuff
going to be a fun time it's going to get
worse for you isn't it right so you put
it here well then when you differentiate
here you're going to have one you're
going to put here this one this is going
to become X but X and this cause and the
minus 1 ba ba ba they're not going to
marry nicely unlike this guy right so
that ends up making the problem worse so
here's what I'm going to transit it and
I agree this doesn't immediately looking
to make things better but it does i'm
going to write cos n to the X as cars x
times now if I pulled out one of them
right this is alien cosine x themselves
right so if I've taken out one how many
are left good okay this doesn't seem
like it improves things money but
actually it's going to be the key to
getting something like this which we can
work with for RVD you okay watch I
wanted to choose like I did over here I
want to choose a you which got
progressively better as i differentiate
it again and again and i wanted to
choose a DV that more or less stayed as
the same thing okay more or less so
which one am I going to choose which one
is more or less every time you
differentiate it or integrate it is
basically going to stay the same and
which one is going to get better and
better and better yeah if you into it
cosine you get site if you integrate
that sign right if you integrate that
you'll get negative cosine you drink
that you're staying in the same degree
of trig functions right so this is the
part that's more or less going to stay
the same and this is the part which
hopefully what the power to reduce just
like it did over here does that make
sense okay so you see my thought process
that's actually um bash this out there
so I'm going to put cars n to the minus
1x up there what's the derivative I'm
gonna need chain rule here right this is
cos x all of the power of n minus 1 so
I'm going to do the outside first the
power comes down at the front the power
reduces by one and then chain rule chain
rule when I missing yep the derivative
of the inside now I admit that looks
gross but don't lose heart yet I'm going
to stick with it what did I got over
here this is the the single cos x that I
pulled up and we already established you
it's different
that integrate that right and you say so
I'm hoping and pray this is going to
sort of come out in the wash for me
let's see what happens I've got the UV
that's going to come out the front so
that looks like sine X cos inverse woods
ok now what appears in here let's have a
look here look carefully when you do
your integral here right what's going to
appear inside the integral I've got V do
you yeah we do you so it looks to me
like there's a couple of things
happening I'm gonna write it all out so
I don't mock up any side by accident
I've got n minus 1 cos and minus 2x this
is a minus sine X there there's a do you
part here is the V part and I've placed
that one on the n so you can see these
two guys are going to get together das
what do you think now when you have a
look at this what sort of things leap
out at you fly all I could do something
here I could do something here what sort
of choices dinners yeah it's very good
so for starters I'm gonna just put this
guy out here your coat that just is what
but this side squared X email it's like
we looked at this in thought uh yeah ok
but just like here these science minutes
we can write as y minus cos squint and
that's going to interact with this do
you see that ok why don't you get a head
start on me on this next line because
though dotes you know rush through this
make sure you get everything right
starts off here but what ends up in that
integral don't forget to take out your
own minus one okay now have you gone to
this line is only a couple of down from
where we left off I want you to pause a
look at this right what have I got now
and in the first place you feel wait a
second Oh is hoping for something it'd
just be nice and neat and easy and it's
not the really obvious what's going on
here this is in fact two integrals right
hand to help you see that I'm going to
separate these out so I've got this guy
at the front end that's all
i Nev in integrated now I'm going to
write this as a pair of integration I
actually need to deal with them
differently you've got here and minus 1
lots of if you just look at this path
let me put this in a company if you've
just got that part and you're
integrating that with respect to X this
looks familiar this is something in that
same family that I started with right i
defined I and as cos x to that power in
this is cos x to a different power n
minus 2 right so i can simply by this
whole thing i can replace that with I
and mines too that's what baddies and
then you have this second integral next
to it right you've still got n minus 1
lots of it because remember it be gone
through this is cookie but if you have a
look at this guy you're like we're
second that's when I began with that I
am this is almost exactly what happened
in our here the negative x cos x example
it's like hey wait he comes back right
I've got n minus 1 lots of the original
integral very interesting yes just
you're exactly right which I'm going to
need in a second okay so so what are
they done here this is this is the
hardest step in getting to the
recurrence relation i really need to
tidy up algebraically now because look
at this right I've got a pattern out of
I end here here here and all the actual
integration by plastic get this room has
been done let's just tidy up a little
bit to finish I want to get my anymore
some people to make that the subject ok
so I'm going to add n minus 1 lots of
iron to both sides to get it away from
this right hand side is that make sense
so on the left hand side I've got i M
plus this yeah do that
and what do I got on the right hand side
there's the UV that I started with and
then you've got this part which
interestingly reminds do it skipped one
do remember when we were doing the
exponential one you got em then you got
n minus 1 your mo 2 etc okay this time
I've skip to n minus 2 why is that
that's a lot of coincidence why is it
I'll give you a clue it has something to
do with the facet is a trig functions
the trig functions not polynomials
remember I compared all there's
something that gets better and better
and better it's nice to do with this
right we chose and you are on the right
track we chose n minus 1 right as our
parts of differentiate so you
differentiate that you skip a step
you've got straight to n minus 2 right
and when these bits get together that's
sort of what comes out and wash once you
simplify everything ok so please note
that in fact this time stepping down
beings you've gone two steps so now you
know just need to tidy up what I got
your left hand side this is there you
see this guy is going to cancel with
that yep so all you're left with is n
lots of my M equals this
and then to finish to make plan the
subject instead of divide through by and
traditionally because we don't write a
huge it's called vinculum the fraction
side we write the 1 over n at the front
and then you don't
okay so so here this now leads to a
couple of questions which i'm not going
to explore completely on the board I'm
going to do one example one application
of this but this leads to the question
not be careful be careful in this case
for example what would it look like if I
say N equals 1 what would happen well if
N equals 1 I don't need to crash my
parts for this do I because if N equals
1 you just getting the integral of cos x
that's fine I'm sorry ok but you have to
make sure that you think that and not
just blindly go to the formula because
otherwise you have this right you'd say
i have 1-2 just following along the
definitions i have negative 1 ok but
that would be according to what I've
define it to me that would because they
don't out of that how are we going to
write it like this right but that's we
know that is that's the integral of sec
x that's following a completely
different theme right this is actually
something in a whole different family
all together ok so this is what I
mentioned before then we will we define
these they're not always defined for all
values and you have to be a little bit
careful with them will dig into some
more specific examples a bit later on